on retrouve à paris corinne khayat
associé du cabinet ihs gg ses avocats
madame khayat bonsoir bonsoir
faut-il s'attendre selon votre analyse à
ce que la transaction pose problème à la
commission européenne ou qu'elle soit
refuser qu'elles soient acceptées à quoi
faut-il s'attendre alors je pense que
c'est trop tôt pour trancher la question
de savoir si la commission européenne va
accepter ou non cette opération ce que
je crois qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
puisqu'on en est au début de ce dossier
c'est qu'on n'est pas dans la même
situation que dans le dossier alstom
siemens alstom siemens ya eu un veto de
la commission
un veto ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que la commission a considéré qu' il y
avait des préoccupations de concurrence
et que l'opération ne permettait pas de
laisser une concurrence effective sur
les marchés concernés et elle à la
commission européenne encore à
considérer que l'opérateur chinois crc
n'était pas une n'était pas présent sur
le marché européen et elle n'avait aucun
élément pour considérer que ce seul
opérateur chinois allait intervenir dans
un délai court
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
opération était refusé je pense que là
nous ne sommes pas dans la même
situation parce que là on perdait on
deux opérateurs on en avait plus qu'un
et c'était un très gros opérateur certes
mais après les cons la concurrence qui
subsistait été peints pour la commission
européenne suffisante
l'un dans la cette opération on va avoir
siemens qui reste on n'est pas dans un
petit monsieur c'est la même situation
c'est une c'est un opérateur très
important et en plus le l'opérateur
chinois que la commission européenne ne
voyais pas arriver dans un délai très
court en europe est déjà arrivé il est
déjà arrivé il a racheté une entreprise
allemande
il a également répondu à des appels
d'offres notamment en grande-bretagne
donc en fait ce que la commission
n'avait pas vu comme un opérateur qui a
les poules qui allait pouvoir intervenir
efficacement sur le marché européen est
maintenant présent soit marché hors
droits je vous écris j'ai pas la même
vous écoute et j'ai l'impression que
selon votre analyse
il ya beaucoup plus de possibilités que
cette transaction alstom bombardier soit
acceptée alors je n'ai pas tous les
éléments mais jeudi en tout cas qu'elle
se présente semble dire quand même d'une
manière de meubles de meilleure manière
que l'opération alstom siemens donc je
ne sais pas si elle va être acceptée où
elle pourrait être aussi accepté avec
des engagements qui pourrait être
demandée par la commission européenne
mais ce qui pouvait être ce qu'on avait
vu assez vite comme étant un veto de la
commission
l'aja a priori bien évidemment je n'ai
pas fait d'études de marché je ne
connais pas évidemment les parts de
marché des opérateurs à l'issue de
l'opération
mais ce que l'on sait c'est qu'on a une
nouvelle concurrence et on a des
concurrents qui sont forts donc la
commission devrait voir d'un nouvel oeil
cette opération advenant que la
commission a posé son véto quels sont
les recours pour alstom et bombardier
ben ayed a recours devant le tribunal de
l'union dans sa b2 dans un délai de deux
mois ça veut dire que lorsque la
commission européenne a supposé que la
commission européenne s'oppose à la
transaction les parties en l'occurrence
avec alstom pourra former un recours
devant le tribunal de l'union pour
demander la nullité nul à sion de la
décision de la commission européenne en
considérant qu effectivement cette
opération ne 2 n'aurait pas dû être
annulés par la commission qui a eu une
mauvaise appréciation de la commission
et donc il pourrait y avoir cela dit des
commis des conditions imposées par la
commission ça pourrait ressembler à quoi
alarmer conditions alors les engagements
qui peuvent être proposées par les
partis ou sollicitées par la commission
sont généralement des engagements ce que
l'on dit structurel la commission n'aime
pas les engagements comportementaux
pourquoi parce que les engagements
structurel a pour objet de permettre par
exemple à un nouvel entrant de
bénéficier d'un certain nombre d'actifs
qui serait qui lui seraient transférés
ou un opérateur qui est présent mais un
petit opérateur grâce à ce transfert
d'actifs ou de savoir-faire
plein de chose qui peut qui peut donner
lieu à un engagement en tout cas des
engagements structurelles ça va
permettre de monde me mettra de monter
en puissance soit nouvel opérateur
soient nouvelles ou un opérateur présent
mais qui n'est pas encore très très
important bien on va suivre cela ça va
prendre un certain temps quand même
avant que la commission européenne se
prononce n'est ce pas c'est un long
processus
alors c'est très long processus
c'est-à-dire une fois que la commission
d'une fois que le dossier de
notification et déposé à la commission
européenne elle a 25 jours ouvrés pour
autoriser en face qu'on appelle en phase
1 l'opération ou d'ouvrir une phase 2 si
elle considère qu'il y a des
préoccupations concurrence est là elle
aura 90 jours ouvrez pour se prononcer
bien corinne khayat à paris merci pour
cet entretien ce soir merci à vous